what's happening there reject nation
we're gonna watch today from new rock
stars cthulhu uh catholic confirmed
darkhold clues and dr strange multiverse
of madness trailer guys hit leave that
like if you can subscribe to new
rockstars if you wish to i would
encourage you to let's get to it people
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness has revealed major
clues in promo footage in high quality
versions of the official poster the
lurking demon cathode the original
author of the darkhold the artifact that
now seems to be the key to wanda maximos
role in this film and this film's final
battle on what we think is wounded gore
mountain all of these details we thought
were just forgotten loose ends from one
division but now upon re-watch are
critical to the biggest crossover event
in mcu history so i'm gonna connect all
these dots well actually reconnect them
because turns out i was right to be so
goddamn obsessed with that animal head
and again
so the official poster for this film
filled with hidden sightings of possible
cameos one additional sighting that we
overlooked until a high-res version of
this poster came out recently a broken
piece of glass right in the middle is
this banged monster over the mouth and
eyes and flesh matching the appearance
of oh yeah damn
wait a minute though i mean the eyes it
looks a little bit more fishy yeah like
a cthulhu
like a fish elder guy yeah yeah for sure
it's got a little bit of megatron's vibe
too you know but uh definitely looks
organic and not
robot yeah it's not gonna look 100 the
same adapt it's real life don't at me if
you pronounce it chauthon or jonathan or
chaithan jacobs euphoria psycho this is
a fictional name written on the pages of
comics based on lovecraftian demonic
names with way too few vowels whose real
pronunciations would actually cause your
brain to explode if you heard them so
let's just clearly find thanks kevon is
known as the original author of the
darkhold and the demon who originally
cursed wanda maximoff with her
witchcraft powers when she was born and
the fact that he shows up on this poster
is no coincidence considering all the
new clues that we are uncovering from
trailer footage pointing to the darkhold
one is mcu origin and the witchcraft
elements from one division
and online trailers show different
moments of wanda and america chavez in
this mysterious temple the back wall
resembles the page in the dark
holy [ __ ]
yes yes
yes
and below other circles inlaid with
sharp geometric angles america leaps off
an altar engraved with a horned animal
head like the animal head on the wall of
agatha's dungeon looks like a ram you
may remember how i interpreted it as the
satanic symbol of baphomet but this
current
is important because it also shows up on
the cover of the dark hole two animal
heads long horns curved around
so below cathode is often depicted with
huge curved horns protruding from his
head just like this therefore this
location is tim korean legend to the
dark hole likely the place it was
written which in marvel lore is a
chamber on wounded gore mountain other
shots in the online trailer in the tv
spot show this blizzard-y mountain holy
crap shadowy structure on a nearby peak
i think that is the exterior of this
temple the chamber known as knight
which gave the spell book its name in
the comics mountain was where in ancient
times
who was the eldest dark sorcerer on
earth inscribed all of his arcane
knowledge on scrolls made from
indestructible parchment and then he
left to another realm known as the
flickering realms or clay then over the
centuries any human who came across the
parchment gave up their souls for its
power and eventually bound it together
into a single volume book calling it the
dark hold meanwhile kefan now a demonic
spiritual presence remained dormant in
wounded mountain okay but wait a minute
is the implication that catholic will be
like a central character or main villain
or just some presence that's alluded to
because if catholic is actually on the
poster for this that would indicate that
he's going to be an actual character
that shows up in here but from
everything we've seen in the trailer i
feel like it would just be like a scene
the kind of thing you like build up for
a while and then eventually you get like
one scene of it and this would be like a
lot of backstory you would have to
unfold i'm sure they would like
minimalize it so it's not overshadowing
the whole experience but with everything
we're already seeing in this one trailer
i'm like there's so much to absorb here
right now yeah and it seems like a
significant enough character to
introduce to her you wouldn't want to
just cram it all into one movie because
then you run the risk of him just being
a regular old baddie who's gonna be
vanquished and gone by the next one i
feel like it would be some kind of
introductory sort of creeping around the
margins thing i'm hoping it's not like a
prometheus ending is what i'm kind of
alluding we'll get all the answers next
time yes
leading to the modern era in which the
high evolutionary herbert wyndham a
geneticist villain highly expected to
appear in guardians volume three maybe
chikuryuji's character used wunderware
mountain as the home for his lab where
he bred human animal hybrids called the
new men and it was here where a woman
named magda gave birth to twins wanda
and pietro maximon and the spirit of
kathan imbued his chaos magic into the
infant wanda so while wanda maximoth has
always been considered a marvel mutant
this curse from c'thon has always been
considered the origin of her sorcery now
the one division series hinted at this
backstory several times in the episode
eight flashback juan to stop the stark
warhead from exploding using low-level
magic that she already had years before
her infinity stone exposure did you stop
that bomb
what used a probability house and when
agatha read the scarlet witch prophecy
from the darkhold it explicitly
mentioned that the scarlet witch was not
born naturally but an intentional
post-birth curse the scarlet witch is
not born she is forged
she has no coven no need for incantation
your power exceeds that of the sorcerer
supreme it's your destiny to destroy the
world and the episode two holy ghosts
included the weird easter egg of bova
milk bova is the name of the human cow
hybrid on biblicor mountain who helped
nurse wanda in pietro oh
[Music]
dude
major details from wanda's origin that
both one division oh [ __ ] ted hurt the
live action mcu to explain wanda's
present condition and the threats she
and dr strange now face in this film we
gotta slow down a little bit i mean this
is just like indisputable at this point
yeah there's just way too much normally
i think like when we're diving into this
stuff it's mainly just a lot of theories
and here this just seems like evidence
upon evidence about evidence but
evidence right now there's already all
kinds of theories and then the one about
normal means already happening is
something that has been theorized like
plenty by this point all across the
board well i mean looking at this it
makes you go back to that time of one
division and think okay with the whole
mephisto wave you know things you might
have gone those are probably just cheeky
nods to older things from the comic
books that aren't gonna actually come to
fruition it feels like you could
probably go back and revisit a bunch of
those things now and go hey maybe they
were actually doing a long game hint
sesh with things like bofa milk i mean
it seems like it would set it up and be
very rewarding to then have people go oh
wow there was something to all that
mysticism that we were speculating on
during one division way back yeah it
sounds like that one this is a sequel to
wanda vision or one division is like
that prequel novel that comes out before
a movie yeah yeah exactly if you want to
know more go watch that it looks like
cathon is going to be revealed as the
original source of wanda's chaos magic
but in the mcu her powers have expanded
far beyond what kathan likely intended
because in addition to her mutant status
in the mcu continuity she became a test
subject for hydra for infinity stone
experimentation her exposure to the mind
stone was the moment her sorcery
amplified so that only then she
witnessed a vision of her scarlet witch
future so it was really cathan's curse
plus her mutant gene plus cosmic
radiation from an infinity stone that
resulted in her becoming a nexus
one that can use the dark hole to do
what other dark sorcerers who bored in
the past could not to split herself into
at least two equally conscious projected
schrodinger selves and navigate
alternate universes within the
multiverse that perfect storm of
influences is what makes wanda unique
why the illuminati fears her so much and
why kathan has now returned to reclaim
his host perhaps even the voices of her
children that wanda thought she heard
was actually the voice of c'thun making
his first move and now here in the
second dr strange film as the actions of
stephen strange is reality to melt into
dark matter beating on that madness
might be c'thun from the flickering
realms and now his well-fed minions are
spilling out of that dimensional dam so
back in one division yeah it was agatha
all along in west view but based on her
worship of that ram head she was likely
one of those many sorcerers over the
ages who gave up her soul for the dark
holes
which is so powerful her fingers fading
to black is all about it's a connection
to kathan and the dark beings from his
realm and now that connection is carried
by wanda we can already see in trailer
footage how those stains start at just
her fingertips but then work their way
down oh my god damn
this host and multiverse of madness will
show us how that curse will have a
lasting impact on the multiverse and on
wanda's fellow mutants follow me on
instagram twitter
following your rockstars subscribe to
direct stars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye my god it's gonna be sci-fi and
supernatural
and a whole bunch of cameos had a whole
bunch of characters so we gotta uncover
witchcraft lore and we're gonna have
time for all that all that feel
satisfying
i know fleshed
out the more we hear about this it's
it's like this is one of those things
where a lot of times movies get so over
theorized we're like so much of it does
not end up coming true but with
everything we're seeing from the
trailers alone and and from what they're
presenting in their marketing it does
feel like we're we're doing just a big
cluster of stuff and my only concern is
will this
smoothly play out that's my only concern
other than that i have all the faith in
marvel guys leave your thoughts down
below thanks for being here holy balls
[Music]